let's take a look at this from uh Daily
Caller check uh check this one out
exclusive video appears to show migrants
tucked away in Hidden room under
military guard at major US airport we
actually have the video here from Daily
Caller I don't know if if everyone it's
it's really I don't even know if you can
see it because the way they needed to
rotate this they just why did the Daily
Caller rotate the video they were busy
it was breaking so in this video uh I'm
going to play I'm going to lower the
volume there's a man it's uh it's up
here at the top you can see a guy in
some kind of military uh uniform I don't
know if he's National Guard or if he's
army or or what he might
be but uh it's hard to see because they
also put their their watermark over it
yeah so I I I don't I don't I don't know
how to show it to you any better those
that are watching but apparently this
was filmed by a state senator let me uh
get the details on on on this state
senator Colton Moore Republican Vice
chairman of the Georgia Freedom caucus
took the video apparently when he tried
to film directly this guy in uniform
went up to him and told him he was done
shut him down tried to take his phone
from him so that would indicate I know
they're trying to be careful here saying
appears to show migrants under military
guard fair point because we don't know
if this guy's actually in the we don't
know who this guy is but I think I think
you can say it does show it now the
question is who is this guy was he given
direct orders to protect illegal
immigrants criminal aliens or is he
acting of his own valtion is he working
private we don't know what's going on
but this is just one grain of sand in
the if you knew actually how bad things
were like look for years we've known the
bid Administration was smuggling
children criminal illegal I should say
for the kids they're brought here by
their parents I guess Criminal Alien
applies I'm not entirely sure but
undocumented children bought brought
here by cartels Smugglers and their
parents are then put on planes by the
bid Administration and flown to
Tennessee to New York to other other
cities and states in the middle of the
night the the it's it's it's it's insane
to me that the B Administration has been
doing this for years do you know what
airport this is in do they say so it's
an Atlanta airport I think is it yeah
Atlanta's heartsfield Jackson look like
I need to take a visit to Atlanta I mean
Kudos of the senator for filming this
but he should have walked up to the
National Guard or whoever it was and
said what are you doing here why are you
guarding this what in what capacity are
you working if he was working
independently then who would have been
funding him NOS well why is he wearing
you would not be you would be against
policy right to wear uniform at least
with the police departments they have to
get approval through the city and
through their police chief I'm not sure
how it works in the military it's got to
be National Guard yeah it doesn't seem
right though because of posi kadas Armed
Forces can't be used for uh domestic law
enforcement unless there are some
exceptions I think the Insurrection Act
is one so I'm assuming it's a national
Guardsman in in Georgia who's been sent
for some reason but I gotta tell you
like I'm going to say this if this is
true these are criminal aliens this
state senator said a whistleblower came
to him and told him this was going on if
that is a room of criminal aliens being
trafficked being smuggled and that
Guardsman is protecting them I want to
see him in prison oh absolutely lock him
up well that's thing is people are so
lenient with everybody that's doing this
I mean like I think the San Antonio PD
Officers that I confronted I think they
should be in prison 100% why are you in
an official capacity or unofficial
capacity in your uniforms you using your
service weapons using your car
allowed to facilitate human trafficking
and smuggling into America when that's
illegal and it's something you should
actually be investigating it's insane it
makes absolutely no sense in my mind and
this isn't the worst of it it's it's
funny that you know this video comes out
this is a a Daily Caller exclusive this
is Jenny te and it's just like I I think
we can all surmise it's it's much worse
than we realize you know James o' for
instance exposes these buses that are
driving criminal aliens there is a
massive human smuggling Network to the
tune of billions of dollars that's been
full swing over the past couple of years
under Joe Biden and Joe Biden's in on it
I got a question is his family getting
Kickbacks probably I mean there you
can't trust anything the Biden family
does in my personal opinion part of this
is anything any nothing he he could
rescue puppies and i' be like what was I
honestly would think it was stage
because there's no way that man can move
fast enough to rescue a puppy but the
thing is the illegal immigration under
Biden has increased by basically a
million people every year cumulatively
at over 6 million people so of course
this system is starting to burst at the
seams I mean if you look at the
Massachusetts at uh Logan Airport in
Boston there are migrants there are
videos of migrants just sleeping on the
floor there's nowhere for them to go for
years Massachusetts has been saying I
mean at least for the last six months I
should say Massachusetts has been
warning we're at capacity we don't have
any place to put anyone we need to do
something and there's sort of no answer
because the federal government
government has refused to uh enforce
immigration law refus to uh Ally itself
with the states that are acting to
defend themselves and now we're all
paying the consequences I mean it is not
obviously I think if you enter this
country illegally you are obviously a
criminal you are doing something wrong
but I can understand that they are also
suffering in the conditions that they
are being housing no one wants to sleep
on the floor at an airport indefinitely
like no one benefits from this system
except for Joe Biden and Democrats who
theoretically could maybe stash people
in States and tip the census uh even
even then they're not just being stashed
in airports either I mean we see it in
Chicago O'Hare Airport too there's a
whole section of tents that are now
being marked off to Media after Ben
berquam went down there and basically
exposed what was going on to the extent
that it was going on and they have
little privacy flyers on it do not enter
you know it's essentially like they're
living there but on top of that a lot of
the times when I talk to these illegals
in the airport they have no idea where
they're going and then their pickup I I
I asked to see what their WhatsApp is
because that's where they do all the
facilitation with the Nos and almost
every single time they're heading to a
local community center that has
basically been I don't know if it's
rented out or what's going on but
they're basically be all being
conglomerated and put in rec centers for
who knows yeah so they're either
sleeping on the rec center floor or
they're sleeping in the airport
somewhere or they're just disappearing
so and even if it's not Kickbacks per se
everyone knows right now that bringing
in that demographic is voting block
material in future elections because the
elections aren't save either a lot of
the time yeah young military age men so
great no I think all of this is is it's
interesting to me to see how much the
conversation around uh the border and
immigration have Shi has shifted over
the last basically 20 years right I mean
there were times when this wasn't a
subject that conservatives would touch
at all and now you know maybe not super
effectively but at least they are
willing to say we're not doing anything
until the border is a top priority and I
think that's the best thing they can do
for their constituents any elected
Republican should know that this isn't
just something that we do to not
encourage people to endanger themselves
by Crossing ille illegally into this
country but it's to say I prioritize the
people who put me in office I want you
guys to feel safe and feel as though the
resources that your tax dollars are
supposed to support go to you it is
weird how like even like during the
Obama Administration illegal border
crossing was something that was at least
they paid lip service to it right in
some way shape or form and that kind of
disappeared when Trump got elected and
it became such a contentious issue kids
in cages things like that and it's kind
of become well I feel like under Obama
the The Narrative was we deser people
need help and it's Our obligation as
this powerful wealthy Nation to you know
help them whatever else they talked
about the Border fence and like it was
at least paid lip service Obama actually
built a portion of the wall as well a
lot of people don't understand that that
part of that wall actually was built in
the Obama Administration also the cages
were built in the Obama ad exactly
that's something people don't know well
no the I think they changed the name
they only became cages when Trump got
elected I think that they were migrant
holding facilities until then and then
they became cages now they holding
facilities again well the biggest
difference between it's all about who's
in who's in office and who knows how to
actually use their power and who
controls the media at this point so when
Democrats are in office it's always a
humanitarian issue and it we need to
save these people We're a nation with
the money to save these people and to
give them the life that they need and
deserve allegedly and then when Trump's
in office or somebody in the GOP is in
office then oh it becomes an issue of we
are essentially attacking these people
and denying them their basic human
rights to illegally cross into our
country so someone super chated this is
um what it say Latin uh 342 that the guy
in the video is wearing a brown round
the Hat mhm and that uh National Guard
doesn't don't have that it's a drill
sergeant hat so it's got to be Federal I
don't know where in the video you can
see that it does look for a brief small
portion there may be a brim off the back
of his head I don't know if you can tell
if that is a full I mean for all we know
he's wearing a backwards baseball cap I
doubt it I a guy in uniform would be
wearing that but uh that would be
interesting uh nonetheless don't know
for sure well the senator that is
recording this video is watching right
now send me the details and I'll be
there in a few days to ask questions cuz
or he can just send you the details and
say yes the guy was wearing a brown
round and describe the patch on his arm
and and and we can figure out if this
guy's working for the federal government
it may be it may be look I mean I mean
that that would be a huge Scandal I'd
imagine if us Armed Forces federally
were facilitating this
because that's I mean I that might be
into the area of a military coup
outright well especially with what you
have going down in Shelby pass right now
you know they they're allowed to stop it
but they're actually not allowed to stop
it according to the Biden Administration
but then on one side if this actually is
somebody in the army or the National
Guard then they're actively facilitating
it while trying to nationalize the
National Guard in Texas so you have a
huge uh you know budding of heads issue
right there I mean this is this is if
that is federal Armed Forces I don't
know what you'd call this cuz you know
I've described what Joe Biden's been
doing as a seditious conspiracy treason
typically refers to or more likely to
refer to acts of war and supporting
enemies treason being a traitor right
what does it mean to be a traitor you're
helping the enemy okay so let's say you
know Taylor and Hanah Clair are fighting
over a slice of uh cake and then I'm
like you know I bought I'm I'm here to
defend you it's your cake and then I go
behind your back and go I'm a traitor I
betrayed you right that's treason
sedition would just be like trying to
destroy this country and it seems like
that's what is going on I love that
example yes but you but I have to
imagine perhaps it's treason I mean if
they're working with cartels it is
treason then because now they're aiding
an abetting an enemy that we are in
active conflict with that's nuts man I
don't I don't know what to say and the
Biden Administration no matter what
happens will say you guys are crazy this
has always been the way things are done
or you didn't see it right this is this
is a right-wing conspiracy and the media
will run cover for them I mean that's I
lose a lot of faith whenever we cover
any stories like this when you hear any
stuff like this I just don't see it
reaching the average American because
everyone's so in their Echo Chambers
anyways the people who will get this
media the ones who are s like searching
it out whether they're using alt media
like this or they watch Fox or oan or
anything like this they already agree
with you and the people that you would
like to reach and hopefully show that
this is happening they're not going to
be watching any media that actually
catches on to this but it's still you
know the information must spread yes and
it it is fascinating to hear how the
migrant crisis has really shifted a lot
of people in this country towards the
and I think it has been a slow boil
issue I think concern about the Border
has increased over the last 10 I mean
even under Trump right when Trump was
saying I want to build the wall there
were people who were excited about that
because they already felt the burdens of
immigration on their Community
especially illegal immigration and so
the idea that under Biden it got worse
on top of everything else that Biden has
done I I don't know that there is enough
spin out there I think it has really
punctured through uh mainstream
narrative I think even people who are
not political start to say yeah why why
are we letting this happen I mean just
my the the San Antonio video that I
filmed earlier this month it breached
over I think 4.5 million just on Twitter
off of tenet's page and not including
the repost on Instagram on Twitter I
mean on multiple different I mean it
went viral on Facebook as well and on
multiple YouTube channels so you're
still breaking into the apparatus of you
know normies so to call and which that's
a good thing which I think if any issue
is going to change people's minds on
what's going on in the country it's
going to be this issue you can go into
any airport I always encourage people to
do this pretty much any airport in the
country look around for Manila or clear
envelopes you're going to see illegal
immigrants on your flight or on flights
around you and wandering throughout the
airport thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net